when I was little my biggest role model
became Wonder Woman I emigrated to the
States and I was about five years old
and I started watching television and I
remember I became infatuated with Wonder
Woman I thought she was so beautiful and
intelligent and always looked amazing
and was empowered and independent and so
I decided I wanted to be just like
Wonder Woman so as a kid I learned how
to run like Wonder Woman Wonder Woman
had a very particular run she would put
her index and little blur together and
then move her arms from side to side as
she ran so I studied her run and
perfected for money and one day when I
was outside playing with all of my
girlfriend's it was running around
practicing my new Wonder Woman run and I
remember my aunt came out of the house
screaming and yelling telling me how
boys weren't supposed to run like that
boys weren't supposed to run like Wonder
Woman boys had to keep their arms down
by their sides and they did not move
since I remember that day my and taught
me how to run like a boy because boys
were not supposed to be wonderful
and so I remember that being as a very
profound lesson about gender and gender
roles and how what I felt was something
that I wanted to be was inappropriate
for what I had been assigned at birth
and so for me I that's how I learned
about gender by learning that I could
not be wonderful
you